the celebrity support is pouring in for
Jonathan Van Ness after revealing in a
New York Times interview he's HIV
positive sharing his diagnosis ahead of
the release of his new memoir
over-the-top the queer eye Starr says
quote I've had nightmares every night
for the past three months because I'm
scared to be this vulnerable with people
the book explores his past addiction
with sex and drugs as well as the day he
found out he was HIV positive writing
that day was just as devastating as you
would think it would be but the sassiest
of the fab 5 who serves as queer as
Beauty Expert says it's important to
eliminate any misconceptions of the
disease and even describes himself as a
member of the beautiful hiv-positive
community after the stars candid
confession his fellow queer eye co-stars
took to Instagram to share their love
Antony Borowski wrote love you proud of
you underneath Vanessa's Instagram post
while Bobbie Burke's added love you baby
boy so proud of you when we caught up
with co-star Kurama Brown at last
night's Emmy Awards he offered up all
his words of support your co-star came
out recently and said a lot of things
that were so brave what are your
feelings on that I'm proud of him you
know these are things that he shared
with us many years many since all the
years we've been working together and
what I love is that he's giving so many
people who don't feel seen an
opportunity to feel see and know that
they can be great as well and that their
circumstances don't define them aside
from je viens co-stars researcher brené
Brown tweeted out the New York Times
article which Venice referenced her
writing dear jvn you make the world a
braver kinder and more gorgeous place
Sophia Bush added just adore you fully
and completely are all lucky to have you
also chiming in at the Emmys was the
good play star Darcy Cardin who gave all
her love for her longtime friends well
Jonathan is an old friend of mine we
used to cut my hair back years ago
just as we know meaning the world
Jonathan Venice is an incredibly special
wonderful selfless like ray of light
that is like put on this earth to help
us and someone you know sort of telling
us their truth is it's like we but we
I'm grateful I love him I'm so proud of
it but and true jvn fashion he's looking
on the bright side writing thanks so
much for your support so far it means
the world
so what do you think about the
overflowing amount of support for Van
Ness how has his confession impacted you
as always let us know in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]